[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh là là mais elle en fait du bruit
cette usine
[Applaudissements]
évidemment vous avez côte à moins que
cette ne fabrique d'avertisseurs ni
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
m
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
décidément c'est maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même le jardinier se plaint regardez ces
salades ont une mauvaise mine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand oui bien sûr c'est plus agréable
travailler dans le calme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'avec tout ce dérangement
ne peut pas se concentrer chauffeur à la
maison c'est bien plus si l'on se
qualifie in art 1 on va y remédier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne idée ou à tout est ici la droite
ou le tout un peu plus tard devant le
tribunal a créé deux chiens aiment bien
à son sort
[Musique]
on a cravaché n'aime pas du tout le
bourg et de lusine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui effectivement aussi chacun s'amuse à
faire tout le bruit que son voisin à la
vie devient rapidement infernal c'est
bien voilà tout le monde d'accord c'est
beaucoup plus sympathique de travailler
dans le calme
où
[Musique]
c'est le jardinier lui il est vraiment
ravi de plus il ne fait plus de bruit
il passe son temps assise dans sa chaise
longue à écouter pousser ses salades
merci à tous à tous
[Musique]
et